alright you know I got to go straight
into Solid Snake now man I got to go
straight into Solid Snake he's got some
of the best skins in the game too I
think I like the black one right there
I'm gonna go with the black one baby
let's go all right folks
Solid Snake unlocked Solid Snake ready
to do battle as we continue clearing
classic mode with more and more and more
characters we just get a did a count
there I think we were at like 23 24 that
we have completed we're a home man
I was bet almost really bad we're gonna
try to make it through every single
Super Smash Brothers ultimate character
not tonight not tonight
you guys know how many characters are in
this game do you know a lot there's a
lot way to may need to do it all in one
night all right I got to remind myself
snakes moves okay down B is the little
mine any places neutral beef throws the
grenade Portero welcome thanks for
stopping by
yes tonight who needs sleep so true so
true
[Music]
it would be pretty awesome to do all in
one sitting I'd like to unlock once I
unlock all the characters I don't even
have all characters unlocked ok forward
B is the rocket oh yeah that's right you
can you can steer it oh man I stay I
love playing with snake and brawl it's
been so long to decorate play brawl
though oh yes sorry Moon Princess missed
that comment above yeah I know the
leopard-print right that's a little
unexpected but I'll take it
weapons and equipment OSP that's the
theme of this one ok so neutral B is the
grenade that's his - right there I love
how he does the the crawl
that's a smash attack when he just pulls
out a rocket launcher point-blank that
places the mine I think the mines are
proximity based as well
like hold on let's throw another one
okay DeeDee Collins just gonna go ahead
and jump right off all right all right
I'm strong experiment with moves you go
on and jump off okay that's what you
want to do yeah I'm trying to remember
about the mind I'm pretty sure if they
walk over it
walk forward
oh no it is okay so you have to detonate
it forgot that all right I remember he
had a really nice the up tilt right
there it's really powerful see that's
his air oh yeah that moved right there's
really powerful to hard to hit
what's oh my gosh dude
you guys saw what happened there right
it happened pretty fast so if you missed
it I was trying to pick up the flaming
box but instead shot at point-blank
range with a rocket launcher he was
above and so exploded him exploded me
too but luckily I did not get knocked
off should just said that's how I
planned it that was totally what I
designed it what I was hoping to do
there just how we drew it up you used to
be able to cancel these when you fire
the rocket Oh see there's another one
dude is this gonna be a theme
moon princess didn't brawl have the
cardboard box it did you know that might
be is that a taunt wait wait I'm stuck
[Music]
that might be a taunt yeah there it is
there you go oh man such I tell ya they
give such fantastic attention to detail
to the characters to all the characters
I mean obviously Nintendo's characters
but even the third-party characters know
[Music]
this has been like the most bizarre run
so far I'm getting so much luck going
right now
retro racket or BOTS doing a nice job
they're welcoming people to the stream
yes indeed thank you all for stopping by
hope you all are having a great start
here we go man
I gotta figure it out how did you cancel
okay there we go I just cancelled it see
if I can do it again
yikes dude yikes
okay so part side gaming thank you for
being subscribed look at that for the
three months thank you so much our side
oh man oh man this is not looking good
too much too much fire the flames flames
they're closing in no no I could use a
ticket not lose any uh I'm not very far
along though let's just keep using gold
save the tickets yeah hard side dude
thank you so much for the three-month
subscription harsh side a fellow
streamer as well folks you want to check
out his stream sometime you stream
tonight hard cider
do you have a stream plan oh yeah you're
still waiting on internet that's right
he just moved let's see what snakes
final mash is gotta have those emotes
that's right dude the retro for the win
emotes and I mean retro for the win
we're getting some bizarre wins right
now like not the best skill we're kind
of looking into some well-placed
explosions so let's take it around for
another pass didn't let you or you
trying to do just use the emote only
plus 0.3 what what you know this this
fits with with Metal Gear you've played
Metal Gear then running into each other
would not be totally outside of the
realm of possibility not gonna spoil
anything for you if you haven't played
Metal Gear games before button it may or
may not oh dude he place that he placed
that right by the flammable box
come on snake you got to be kidding me
man
you've got to be kidding me I'm pretty
sure if we ever
I shouldn't say if win when we unlock
that next emote Christine has already
come up with a great idea for it it's a
phrase I say a lot oh crap dude he's got
his final smash doesn't he no man no I
don't want to kick it and explode it I
want to pick it up wait wait so many
bombs so many moms thought it was gonna
let you share your anniversary message
again oh the prompt remains on the
screen I see it I see the message does
everybody else see I mean we should make
sure it's read right we should make sure
it's read the suspense now man our sides
a three month message he just gave up
toto
oh that was that was a three month
message see that you guys were so
anxious to hear about
okay so hitting shield cancels the the
rocket I didn't figure that out see if
anything else cancels it I'll tell you
everybody's died two explosions in this
run every single time it's been people
dying to explosions all right we got one
more and then the final stage who's it
gonna be for the final boss if it's
something from Metal Gear guys I'm gonna
lose my mind you just tell you right now
just I'm just gonna lose my mind I
played so many shooter games that
there's something that just makes me
panic when he pulls out a rocket
launcher to shoot it so close because
you expect it to damage you because you
can't you can't use a rocket launcher
like that in any other game see look at
that right there like definitely take a
little damage from that just a little
bit let me throw oh no it's not good
this is not good
you piss it's coming yeah we're just
gonna go ahead and skip that folks if
you're out there watching again man this
this guy is just not that it's not that
great
I'm trying to do something where I play
through every character classic mode and
so I haven't even spent a lot of time
with a single character yet I thought it
might be that guy again
gallium we just saw him in the
playthrough before when we were using
jeez I already forgot that we were using
King K rool yeah and this kind of neat
kind of fits with metal gear right so
it's not actually from metal gear but
it's sort of the the next best thing he
looks like something from like a
Saturday morning version of Metal Gear
[Music]
dude we did way better with King K rool
on him
[Music]
all right yeah I'll just keep my
distance
[Music]
No
oh he's mad now guys remember this stage
[Music]
yikes yikes man why does it I thought I
was just placing it if you forget where
you placed that mind it will mess you up
gallium you little punk it will mess you
up just as much as it will mess the
enemy up
there we go of course 0% look at that
flawless victory right oh yeah we died
right we died
just don't tell anybody don't tell
anybody you're just steamrolling well we
were for a little bit till we started
getting hit by the explosions we started
getting hit by one - meaning explosions
there
nice dude har psyched taken the top spot
over on the the recently recognized
supporters of the stream whether you
follow the stream whether you subscribe
to the stream whether you host the
stream whether you raid the stream all
of those will have a spot over there
those are the three most recent
supporters of the stream right there you
got hardside gaming with the resub urban
shrug delight with the follow and then
cat dad TV with a host couple nights ago
appreciate that from him dude here we go
we're just unlocking them left and right
unlocking new characters left and right
I believe this is another Belmont yes
indeed Richter Belmont another
Castlevania character yeah man I used to
be so much better with snake that attack
right there hold on see if I can do it
again that one that's a really good
attack when you can land it
feel like I need to use his tilts more
than his smash attack like the rocket
takes so long to come out yet that
little up kick right there that's just
an up tilt comes out so much faster and
has look at the 19 maybe better knock
back than the smash attack right there
richter welcome to the roster buddy so
happy you could join us here